for more on that aid that the united
states is offering ukraine and the
details of the u.s officials trip to
keeve let's bring in nancy cordes at the
white house nancy good morning vlad good
morning to you in a middle of the night
press conference secretaries blinken and
austin said that they made the trip from
poland to kyiv by train and that they
went directly to the presidential palace
in kyiv without stopping for a tour of
the region in kiev they met they said
for three hours with president zielinski
and his senior team this risky mission
meant to send a message of course that
the u.s is committed to ukraine and is
not going anywhere now notably during
the trip the leaders announced that the
u.s embassy in kiev is going to reopen
in the coming weeks and that u.s
diplomats are actually going to start
making day trips into the country next
week starting in levee in the west so
business back to
something like usual the president is
also this morning at long last finally
naming a u.s ambassador to ukraine her
name is bridget brink she is the current
u.s ambassador to slovakia and therefore
has pretty deep knowledge of the region
on the money front secretary blinken and
austin announced more than 700 million
dollars in new military aid to ukraine
and to its neighboring allies that
brings the total amount of u.s military
assistance to 3.7 billion dollars since
the start of the invasion now none of
this of course is sitting well with
moscow which sent a letter demanding
that the u.s stop supplying weapons to
ukraine but the secretary of defense is
already in germany this morning meeting
with allies about ways to coordinate on
military aid as for president biden
himself he has made no secret of the
fact that he would like to visit ukraine
but at this point jamie there are no
public plans to do so because of the
security situation yeah a little risky
right now nancy thank you